[Musique]
ce qui pose un autre problème meutre
invités politiques ce matin c'est annick
girardin bonjour d'être avec nous vous
êtes là ministre de la mer on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représentée par
stéphane vernet qui dirige le bureau
parisien du journal ouest france bonjour
stéphane bonjour orione on commence
annick girardin avec la crise sanitaire
évidemment et ces nouvelles mesures
annoncées hier par sébastien lecornu le
ministre d outre-mer et 7 certaines qui
sera désormais mis en place pour les
liaisons de l'hexagone vers les
outre-mer est ce que c'est une
précaution comprend pour les autres
maires ou est ce qu'il ya une réelle
inquiétude sur place des variants qui
émerge est est ce que il ya un danger
pour les outremers aujourd'hui avec ces
variants vous savez dans les territoires
ultramarins il ya une difficulté qui est
la prise en charge sanitaire qui est
toujours plus complexes d'abord parce
que l'éloignement et ensuite la clé
capacité d'accueil dans les territoires
donc à une vigilance particulière du
gouvernement depuis le début de la
présence du co vide dans ces territoires
ultramarins avec une spécificité c'est à
dire justement la prise en compte de la
spécificité si comme partout ailleurs au
début du coc vide on a effectivement
confiné très vite les les techniques de
lutte contre le coc vides ont été
différentes selon les territoires et se
sont adaptés c'est ce que moi j'ai
toujours appelé le réflexe ultramar a
donc ça c'est très bien qu'on puisse
effectivement conserver cette palette
d'outils qui va alors à l'époque c'était
une des 14 jeunes aujourd'hui des septs
n en passant par par le texte le test
toujours obligatoire dans les
territoires ultramarins on allons vers
des motifs impérieux pour se rendre dans
les territoires d'outre-mer certains
territoires d'outre-mer se sent
extrêmement fermé jamais réouvert
d'ailleurs et d'autres ont réouvert
selon effectivement les résultats de
leur lutte alors ce sont des îles donc
c'est plus facile à contrôler sauf la
guyane bien entendu rappelons nous de la
difficulté de la guyane quand l'épidémie
est montée du du brésil c'est plus
compliqué c'est plus difficile
je crois qu'il faut rester très vigilant
et il faut jamais laisser le coc vide
à aucun moment se développer dans des
territoires plus fragiles qu'ailleurs
mais ce qu'on a des chiffres aujourd'hui
de la présence de ces variants dans les
outre-mer alors moi je ne suis pas en
détail chaque territoire n'est plus le
tableau 2
ça n'a échappé à personne ne suit plus
la mise d outre mer on a servi toujours
récurrent déjà les verts en l'occurrence
toujours mais on a quelques que le
chiffre moi j'ai eu quelques le chiffre
global aujourd'hui mais territoire par
territoire effectivement les choses sans
suivi et sur les territoires
il y as avec les les élus avec les
socioprofessionnels travail d'animation
qui sont fait à la fois par les préfets
et les ars il ya une vraie prise de
conscience du virus et de responsabilité
de chacun ce qui est un danger pour
l'économie des îles je pense notamment
aux antilles guadeloupe martinique où la
polynésie française 7,70 elle va avoir
un impact terrible sur la saison
touristique comme d'ailleurs la première
vague ça a été terrible pour les
territoriales en décembre la saison
touristique a été bonne dans l'équipe
essentiellement du tourisme
à partir du moment où on se dit ça on
sait pertinemment que dès qu'on met des
contraintes qui a moins de touristes
dans les territoires obligatoirement il
souffre et c'est pour ça que
l'accompagnement du gouvernement dans
les territoires ultramarins comme sur
l'ensemble de l'île de l'hexagone est un
impératif et je crois je crois et je
peux dire que le gouvernement est à la
hauteur des besoins des territoires et
dans les territoires ultramarins il ya
souvent eu d'ailleurs des compléments de
prise en charge ou des aménagements et
ça aussi c'est bien qu'on l'ait laissée
à la main des préfets de manière à ce
que ce soit adaptée à chaque besoin
la campagne de vaccination pour les plus
de 75 ans a débuté en métropole et dans
les territoires ultramarins c'est
difficile d'acheminer les doses de
vaccins dans ces territoires
ben alors les choses sont toujours plus
compliquées dans les territoires
ultramarins d'abord parce qu'il faut
acheminer les doses et ensuite parce
qu'il faut une organisation particulière
dans certains territoires n'ya pas
obligatoirement les frigos nécessaire je
pense aux tout petits territoires dont
les organisations dans une différente
mais sébastien lecornu sait très bien
faire ça et suit les dossiers et là
encore la clé c'est la spécificité mais
personne ne sera jamais oublié ni dans
l'accompagnement et économiques
nécessaires ni sur le volet sur le volet
santé et ça c'est important si je veux
vous voulez que je vous parle de mon
territoire
ce quai saint pierre et miquelon il sera
décidé effectivement d'avoir une seule
vaccination en une seule fois pour toute
la population
et ça c'est comme ça que ses pensées
tout simplement parce que c'est plus
facile et plus adapté et dans les petits
territoires
il y aura recours au vaccin moderna qui
est plus facile à stocker claude kaiser
tu auras fait probablement du coup un
petit décalage de vélo fait y aura un
décalage et toute la population sera
traitée ensemble alors que dans
l'hexagone effectivement on a une règle
c'est d'abord effectivement les
personnes âgées en ehpad fragile et
ensuite bien sûr maintenant il faut s'en
féliciter les plus de 75 ans et je crois
qu'on a un million de personnes qui ces
mots qui se sont mobilisés aujourd'hui
tu crois que c'est ça ce qu'il faut dire
aujourd'hui on a il ya eu beaucoup d'
enquêtes qui ont dit que les français ne
souhaitait pas se vacciner en grande
partie et bien ils sont là et ils ont ce
souhait et ça se veut tendance est en
train de s'inverser a coûté si vous me
le dites ce matin je joue je vous écoute
mais en même temps voilà les dernières
informations que moi j'avais c'est qu'on
peut se féliciter de l'engagement des
gens on revient en métropole cette fois
est ce que il ya une inquiétude laotien
sur les contrôles en métropole est ce
qu'il ya des contrôles spécifiques dans
les ports au départ et à l'arrivée il ya
des contrôles comme régulièrement ya pu
y avoir dans des aéroports ou dans ou
dans des ports ce qu'il faut se dire
c'est sur laquelle avec la question du
duc au vide c'est que les porcs ont joué
leur rôle dans toute la première vague
et la deuxième sur on est présent on est
là pour l'avitaillement du territoire
pareil effectivement pour les armateurs
tous ceux qui transportent les biens de
consommation dont nous avons besoin et
notamment tout ce qui est alimentaire la
difficulté que celle de la ministre de
la mer sur le sujet qu vide c'est c'est
beaucoup tout ce qui relève de marc à
vous savez les navires qui sont sûres
sur l'ensemble de nos océans fondé
changement d'équipage et c'est
changement d'équipage sont extrêmement
compliquées en période de coheed parce
que fermeture de certains territoires
parce que exigences particulières et
donc on a eu notamment sur la première
vague a travaillé sur
le rapatriement ou les échanges affaires
et la réunion a été une base de transit
un certain nombre de marins on a la
france a aidé 15 milles marins a
effectivement pouvoir rentrer chez eux
ou reprendre leur embarquement sur cette
deuxième vague
l'april ma préoccupation reste toujours
identique
elle est également d'ailleurs avec la
question du du vaccin qui petit à petit
peu peut-être être réclamés dans
certains pays reposait un problème à nos
à nos marins va falloir renforcer les
contrôles ou les où les gens de mer font
preuve de beaucoup de responsabilités en
la matière notamment pour déclarer
d'éventuels d'éventuels cas à bord des
choses comme ça il ya alors je crois
qu'il faut faut savoir que côté français
nous avons et vous y participez
énormément parler du decaux vide de ses
risques et sensibiliser et
responsabiliser l'ensemble du recul bien
compris les marins et sachez que que ce
soit les armateurs que soient les marins
que ce soit les ports aujourd'hui sont
des des organismes extrêmement ou des
personnes extrêmement responsable et
qu'il n'y a pas eu de kloster
particulier ni dans la première vague
n'est ni aujourd'hui du duc au vide sur
c'est sur ces sites
est ce qu'il ya des obligations
sanitaires particulière pour les bateaux
qui bat pavillon français ou est ce que
vous comptez sur la responsabilité des
équipages et à la responsabilité il ya
des armateurs qui ont mis des conditions
de ré embarquement à bord c'est géré par
les armateurs même et sur le volet pêche
la question du coc vide a été plutôt
l'inconvénient de ne pas pouvoir aller
en mer ou de ne pas pouvoir
effectivement exercer leur métier comme
il le voulait et là il ya eu un
accompagnement de l'état pour les uns
comme pour les autres qui est identique
ou presque à l'ensemble des des
propositions qui ont été faites par le
gouvernement pour l'ensemble des
entreprises pour finir sur cette crise
sanitaire on va parler on va dire un mot
des entreprises aquacoles qui sont
évidemment touché par la crise sanitaire
vous avez mis en place vendredi avec
julien de normandie qui est le ministre
de l'agriculture des mesures spécifiques
à ce que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
écoutez on a annoncé
trois cent mille euros dead pour les
aquaculteurs c'est une des filières de
la pêche et de l'aquaculture qui n'avait
pas complètement était pris en compte
où on n'avait pas exactement vu les
détails de la prise en charge de ces de
ses aquaculteurs et donc c'est chose
faite aujourd'hui on a pu les recevoir
plusieurs fois un travail
d'accompagnement a été fait je crois que
le plus important pour moi comme pour
julien de normandie c'est d'être sur le
terrain aux côtés de ceux qui souffrent
de des conséquences du coc vite que ce
soit les pêcheurs les aquaculteurs où
l'ensemble des des marins en ski en ce
qui me concerne
être présent et répondre à leurs besoins
parce que bien sûr qu'on a appréhendé et
envisager toutes les difficultés mais il
ya toujours la maille un peu trop large
qui fait qu' une personne une entreprise
ne peut pas être pris en charge ou ne
peut pas avoir une réponse et c'est ça
auquel il faut veiller c'est que chacun
soit accompagnée que personne ne reste
sur le bord de la route
on va parler d'un sujet d'inquiétude
pour nos pêcheurs célèbre excite
stéphane oui alors le il ya eu des
accords sur la pêche mais est-ce que
tout est réglé pour autant comment
est-ce que les choses se passent il
était notamment prévu une réduction
progressive des quotas de pêche de 25% 2
d'ici 2026 qu'est ce qu'elles sont les
compensations qu'ils sont qui sont qui
sont négociés et comment est ce qu elles
vont se mettre en place
alors peut-être rappeler parce que c'est
important qu'ils aient un accord de
pêche
il ya quelques semaines avant noël on
m'aurait posé la question que j'ai été
un peu pessimiste et donc on a cet
accord et je vous rappeler que cet
accord c'est d'abord parce qu'il ya eu
un rôle déterminant dans le combat c'est
celui du président emmanuel macron qui
s'est totalement impliqué et avec
clément bonne nous avons fait en sorte
que les intérêts
des pêcheurs européens et les intérêts
des pêcheurs français soit défendu
rappelez vous on avait dit il a été dit
le gouvernement l'a rappelé le premier
ministre l'a rappelé dans les autres ans
avant effectivement la connaissance de
cet accord les pêcheurs ne se rend pas
les victimes ou ne paieront pas la
facture de la décision d'ubs rexie pts
alors cet accord nous le connaissons le
24 décembre au soir et jusqu'à 20h30
avec clément bonne avec le président de
la république je ferais tout à fait nous
sommes en contact des pêcheurs et
jusqu'au bout pourquoi parce que les
propositions françaises ont toujours été
regardée avec les socioprofessionnels et
ça c'est important parce que quand
l'accord arrive on l'a pas en totalité
mais on sait déjà quelles sont les
lignes rouges qui ont été respectées et
puis celle qu'on a un peu dépassé
mais rappelons nous que c'était 80 % que
voulait récupérer de leurs quotas les
britanniques
et bien c'est 25% et rappelons nous
qu'il voulait qu'en sorte de la totalité
de leur zoo et aujourd'hui on a gardé la
totalité des accès alors bien sûr il ya
des contraintes bien sûr y avait les
conditions il ya des points de friction
aussi il ya des conditions alors mettre
un accord en place c'est des points de
friction
mais mais mais on est passé à côté de la
catastrophe alors mettre cet accord en
place c'est pas simple c'est pas simple
parce que pour aller pêcher dans les
dents la z du royaume uni les
autorisations ont été données pour aller
pêcher dans la zone des 6 12 milles du
royaume uni comme dans les zones de nos
voisins de jersey et guernesey et à la
condition d'antériorité et c'est ça qui
aujourd'hui pose un certain nombre de
petites des analyses de
est ce qu'on peut parler on peut
s'arrêter sur le cas spécifique de gérer
ça se passe pas très bien parce que il
était question c'est là les accords
mettent fin aux gros permis de la baie
de granville
sauf qu'il était question d'un délai de
quatre mois pour renégocier les accès
aux autres jersey et que les les
jersiais roues ont fermé leur au
dimanche
ils n'acceptent plus que 57 navires dont
36 normand et vous avez cent dix neuf
bateaux normands qui sont exclues d'un
coup alors que les pêcheurs normands
pensaient avoir quatre mois pour
négocier l'accès à leur zoo donc du coup
on voit bien qu'il ya aussi malgré les
accords on voit bien qu'il ya aussi des
coups de canifs ou des choses qui était
pas prévu qu'ils sont en train de se
passer comment comment est ce que vous
pouvez intervenir pour les aider à
régler ce type de différend
alors sachez qu'on intervient et qu'on
fait que ça d'ailleurs avec à nouveau
clément clément bonne et puis d'ailleurs
je le fais aussi régulièrement avec le
commissaire européen et nous aurons
également avec michel barnier dans les
quelques heures qui viennent une
rencontre sur ce sujet parce
qu'effectivement on est dans l'analyse
et la mise en application d'un accord
jamais facile parce que il faut là aussi
pouvoir les analyser alors qu'est ce qui
se passe sur jersey et guernesey c'est
que et notamment jersey c'est que le
traité de de la baie de granville et
écraser on va dire où est supprimé si on
veut que tout le monde loc le comprendre
qu'on prenne part cet accord de pêche
est donc cet accord de pêche prime sur
le traité dit simplement que nous
pouvons aller dans les eaux de jersey
avec des licences provisoire et que ces
licences provisoires sont donnés avec
une antériorité c'est comme ça que c'est
compris alors c'est pas il ya que où il
n'ya plus que 57 c'est que pour
l'instant il ya des dossiers qui ont été
validés et d'autres pour lequel jersey
comme d'ailleurs le royaume uni pour les
6 12 mille demandes des compléments
d'information pour démontrer que les
pêcheurs et une autre en thériault rites
et moi j'ai proposé et ça s'appelle du
bon voisinage et je continue à le faire
que dans cette période de transition
tous ceux qui allaient puisse
effectivement se rendre dans les eaux de
jersey comme d'ailleurs je le souhaite
et on pourra l'évoqué est gelée redit à
michel barnier je le redis aux
commissaires que
les français puissent aller pêcher dans
les 6 12 milles du royaume uni et on
fera dans ces trois mois le bilan ou
l'analyse complète des dossiers et
d'ailleurs c'est réciproque puisque
jersey viennent pêcher dans les eaux
françaises et nous avons et la
commission a là aussi validé les choses
soient qu'il faut le faire en bande
voyez ce boa zonage est en bonne
intelligence et c'est ça que je continue
effectivement apporté et c'est important
alors vous parliez tout à l'heure et je
crois que je n'ai pas complètement
répondu à cette question sur
l'accompagnement parce que bien sûr que
ce soit sur le temps que ça prend pour
avoir les licences trop de temps à mon
goût puisque la commission s'était
engagé à 15 jours 15 jours les a
largement dépassées donc l'énervement
mécontentement des pêcheurs est normal
c'est pour ça que je me suis rendu
plusieurs fois dans plusieurs ports de
pêche en normandie comme quand mon
bretagne à la fois pour expliquer la
méthode la manière de travailler et en
même temps pour présenter le plan
d'accompagnement puisque de toute façon
moins 25% de quotas en valeur ça veut
dire des pertes pour les pêcheurs il
fallait donc un plan d'accompagnement
plan d'accompagnement validé par le
premier ministre souhaitait pas le pr
vénisse validé par le premier ministre
avant que l'accord soit connue c'est à
dire qui a pris en compte toutes les
conditions possibles où toutes les
difficultés possibles y compris en cas
de non accord donc on a une palette
d'outils à court à moyen et à long terme
qui accompagne la pêche y compris dans
la transition nécessaire et ça c'est
important et j'ai voulu que ya également
des ressources humaines supplémentaires
sur les territoires pour accompagner au
quotidien les pêcheurs à court terme ça
veut dire quoi à court terme ça veut
dire des aides qui peuvent aller jusqu'à
30000 euros immédiatement pour la
trésorerie des entreprises
à moyen terme c'est à la fois le la
compensation de la perte des cheveux du
chiffre d'affaires y compris jusqu'en
2026 puisque je vous le rappelle
l'accord et pour cinq ans et demi
et puis sur du plus long terme et c'est
pour ça que là je parle de d'adaptation
de transformation de la filière on est
dans l'extension de l'activité partielle
mais on est aussi dans les sorties de
flotte une sortie de flotte s'est on
indemnise le patron pêcheur pour qu'ils
sortent avec son navire
de la flotte de la formation en même
temps parce qu'on traite les hommes les
bateaux les hommes de manière à ce qu'on
puisse former pour revenir dans la
filière s'ils le souhaitent dans
d'autres et dans d'autres niveaux de la
filière
et puis des aides à l'investissement
tout ça pour les pêcheurs mais aussi
pour l'ensemble de la filière
et puis la prise en compte aussi des
territoires puisque c'est des hommes des
femmes vivent sur des territoires et qui
a une conséquence clos battait justement
vous parlez de l'inquiétude des pêcheurs
inquiétudes aussi des élus locaux la
semaine dernière on était à
boulogne-sur-mer poursuivre justement
les pêcheurs face aubry site on a
rencontré frédéric cuvillier le maire de
la ville
on va l'écouter il était au micro de
jérôme rabier il ya l'accord qui est
d'accord général duval site
mais pour ce qui est du domaine de la
pêche de toute la filière halieutique
il convient d'avoir ce que j'appelle des
accords dans l'accord et au delà des
zones de pêche il y à des conditions
dans lesquelles nous pourrons assurer
l'approvisionnement à boulogne comment
les flux vont pouvoir de produits
asiatiques vont pouvoir se réaliser
honte à vous ment en provenance
d'irlande écosse et transitant par la
grande bretagne
comment on fait de rassurer faudrait
qu'il y ait alors frédéric cuvillier a
été ministre de la pêche dont on connaît
extrêmement bien le sujet et nous
travaillons ensemble depuis le début de
ces négociations ou du moins depuis que
je suis arrivé à la tête de ce ministère
en juillet en juillet dernier
ce qui est clair c'est que les autres
france risque d'être très touché par cet
accord de pêche par le par le break site
pour deux raisons d'abord parce que
effectivement c'est un port de pêche
conséquent et ensuite parce que
transitent par par boulogne beaucoup de
deux produits de la pêche qui sont
transformés dont la région est donc ça
pouvait être des double peine selon les
résultats de la négociation
frédéric cuvillier a raison de dire il
ya à la fois effectivement
l'accompagnement sur le volet pêche pour
les pêcheurs français leur
accompagnement et sur l'ensemble de la
filière c'est pour ça que j'ai insisté
tout à l'heure pour dire que les aides
sont pour l'ensemble de la filière
et puis il a raison aussi de se
préoccuper et nous le faisons c'est à
dire aussi du marché
le royaume uni livre la plupart de 2 c
de ces poissons le produit de leur pêche
en france comme d'ailleurs jersey le
fait également et donc au delà des zones
de pêche de l'axé il ya le flux
également qui est important la france a
mis les moyens là aussi un pour
faciliter le flux et 2 pour le garantir
voyez des inquiétudes dont on a vu
notamment hier la colère des pêcheurs
écossais qui disent que il ya trop de
paperasse je cite que du coup les
produits mettre trop de temps à arriver
dans l'union européenne avec des risques
d'un de jeter s'est produit parce qu'ils
auront mis trop de temps à y arriver
comment on fait pour lutter contre ça
qu'on sait pas la problématique que
français c'est à dire qu'en vrai le
royaume uni il n'était pas prêt le
royaume uni qui décide de sortir de l'ue
n'est pas prêt ne s'est pas préparé à la
fois sur ce qui est administratif ce qui
nécessite des clés nécessaires en
ressources humaines
contrairement à la france qui a renforcé
les ressources humaines sur l'ensemble
de son littoral et notamment dans l'est
dans les outrances et donc on voit bien
que il ya une difficulté aujourd'hui est
celle du royaume uni au royaume uni qui
est pas du tout à la hauteur de ces
annonces qui ne qui a quelque part
largement menti à l'ensemble du de ces
de ces populations
une dernière question stéphane même deux
dernières questions pour vous cet effet
une qui soit rapide sur le projet de
parc éolien au large du cotentin en fait
qui verra le jour en 2022 donc mille
1000 mégawatts
huit cent mille foyers service est à 32
kilomètres des côtes donc c'est assez
loin du c'est loin du littoral est ce
que ce type de grands projets en fait et
sera ouvert à la pêche ou ça fait partie
des zones d'exclusion comment comment ça
fonctionne alors sur les gmr d'ailleurs
il faut dire aux français parce qu'on en
parle depuis très très longtemps de ddo
lienne en mer aujourd'hui en france nous
en avons qu'une
alors il ya plusieurs projets plusieurs
grands projets bien ça c'est en
normandie c'est catherine chabaud et non
mais c'est bien de le rappeler mais il y
en a une qui tourne aujourd'hui et donc
il ya plusieurs projets qui ont été des
projets ambitieux qui ont été avancées
par le gouvernement qui ont été
négociées par le passé pas toujours très
bien barbara pompili l'a dit
il ya très peu de temps publiquement
aujourd'hui l'arrivée du du ministère de
la mer à quel intérêt dans ses projets
c'est de dire alors moi je définis mon
ministère comme le ministère de la
planification en mer c'est important le
ministère des usages et des usagers est
donc ce type de grand projet doit être
pris en compte dans le cadre d'une d'une
planification globale à l'avenir alors
bien sûr on dit tout ce que c'est trop
long dans la négociation dans les
échanges avec les usagers c'est pas que
c'est roland c'est que derrière il ya un
certain nombre de démarches qui sont
toujours compliquées ou ou juridiques
souvent parce qu'on n'a pas pris le
temps de travailler avec les
utilisateurs avec les usagers de leur
garantir les conditions futures de
l'accès à la mer et notamment pour les
pêcheurs normalement je me suis engagé
comme celui là je me suis engagé à ce qu
on travaille sur ces solutions alors sur
les parcs du passé c'est compliqué pour
moi parce que les choses ont été
garantis sur le revenu sur les sur les
parts de l'aviron n'a effectivement un
travail qui se fait prenant l'exemple de
la méditerranée sur lesquels aujourd'hui
on travaille sur des éoliennes en mer
flottante puisque sur la méditerranée
c'est le choix qui a été fait et bien le
travail est de très grande qualité
commencé largement en amont il prend en
compte tous les usagers et tous les
usages et ils recherchent les espaces où
certes ça a un intérêt pour les énergies
renouvelables en mer mais aussi ça ne
bloque pas ni les pêcheurs ni les autres
utilisateurs
alors il ya toujours effectivement un
impact qui est qui qui restent mais
c'est important de le faire un saint
nazaire le projet qui a été mis en place
a pris en compte les pêcheurs ça s'est
très bien passé les pêcheurs ont été
indemnisées le temps de la pose des
câbles et ont été associés en permanence
au travail qui a été fait donc quand on
les industriels en barque
on va le dire comme ça l'ensemble des
usagers avec eux et que les élus des
territoires en aussi travaillé en amont
le sujet bien ça se passe bien et moi
depuis mon arrivée je veille à ce que
les nouveaux projets se passent de cette
manière là et merci beaucoup merci
madame la ministre est revenue nos vins
ce matin nous parler de ces sujets dont
on parle moins mais qui sont pourtant
importants merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
stéphane en regardant une nouvelle
france certes un masque en tissu des
conseillers face au co vide c'est à la
une de votre journal ce matin merci
stéphane on passe ensuite au club de
territoire
[Musique]